se presenta con mucha expectativa
teniendo en cuenta que ha habido
campañas de cabildeo bastante duras por
parte de la republicano presidente de la
cámara representante Kevin mccarthy y
del presidente
bidenyana llamado a decenas de
congresistas personalmente para contar
con el apoyo lograr esa mayoría de más
de 218 votos en la cámara de
representantes se sobreentiende que los
radicales conservadores republicanos y
los más liberales demócratas no van a
apoyar este proyecto por las quejas que
plantean ellos los radicales
conservadores dicen que no es suficiente
el presupuesto que se designó para
defensa en los próximos años y los
liberales dicen que no hay suficiente
plata para los programas sociales Así
que ellos están excluidos de ese apoyo
que quieren lograr tanto
los moderados republicanos y los
moderados demócratas para pasar este
proyecto de ley y evitar el deporte
financiero que según se empezaría a dar
a partir de el 5 de junio
es decir este fin de semana tendría
Entonces el senado una vez sea aprobado
acá en cámara de representantes este
proyecto de ley para levantar el techo
de la deuda del senado tendría Entonces
el fin de semana Para probarlo también y
que sea yo quien lo firme ya como ley
Cristóbal pues estaremos pendientes de
estos debates en esta Cuenta atrás pero
le quiero trasladar una pregunta que
seguramente comparte gran parte de
nuestra audiencia y es cómo ha influido
la ayuda que Estados Unidos ha enviado a
Ucrania a que se haya superado en un
primer momento el límite del gasto
público
sin duda Estados Unidos es el país de
lejos que más dinero le ha
enviado a Ucrania se ha en gastos
administrativos pero también en ayuda en
defensa sin embargo cuando se compara el
porcentaje que ocupa defensa en el
presupuesto total de Estados Unidos este
no supera el 2025 por ciento Así que
aunque sí es mucha la ayuda que Estados
Unidos le ha enviado a Ucrania pues es
marginal la influencia que ese dinero
que se le ha enviado a Ucrania a
contribuido a
lograr llegar a este techo de gasto y
a tener que empujar a que el tesoro
pueda emitir más bonos y pueda seguir
financiándose es decir levantar el techo
de la deuda para que Estados Unidos
pueda seguir con sus obligaciones
obligaciones que son bastante
significativas también en seguridad
social que ocupa más de El 25% del
presupuesto general en educación en
salud y en otros gastos para mantener la
cantidad de agencias que tiene este
gobierno agencia ambiental agencia de
comunicaciones agencia de drogas y
alimentos muchas agencias y muchos
gastos públicos que esos son
precisamente los que se quieren
financiar porque ahí Precisamente es por
ejemplo en el caso de los veteranos de
guerra donde más ruido está generando y
de donde políticamente más se pegan los
partidos para atraer votantes de Cara a
elecciones regionales y federales